If you want to hear about a kids movie clown
that scarred an entire generation, stick around
to the end of this video.
So we've talked about horror movie clowns,
I've written you a creepy clown story and
short film, and it kind of begs the question,
are there ever any actual funny clowns who
aren't just horrifying?
I can only think of one really.
But why ARE so many people afraid of clowns?
Maybe they're just naturally scary, because
the makeup of a clown often contrasts and
hides their true facial expressions, tapping
into the fear of the unknown, kind of similar
to the fear of the dark.
But maybe it's a deep seeded fear planted
from the point of childhood, because if you
look at some of the many clowns seen in kids
movies, there are some really disturbing ones.
And most of them come from old Disney movies,
like Dumbo from 1941.
This movie is about a circus elephant, so
you can bet there are a lot of clowns, but
there's one scene in particular that stands
out.
Dumbo has a dream about this parade of pink
elephants, which are already kind of creepy
with their empty eye sockets and Fauvism inspired
art style...
so when they start to appear as clowns, things
quickly break down into an acid trip nightmare.
And as kind of a side note, I always think
the title at the end of the movie is also
pretty messed up.
I mean look at that guy.
It looks like he's crawling out from behind
that gong to feast on you.
Of course, this is kind of an older movie
so I think that adds to the creep factor a
little bit.
Another circus clown appearance can be seen
in Red's Dream, a PIXAR short from 1987.
This was one of the earliest CG animated films
about a unicycle who dreams of being in the
circus, and what makes this so disturbing
is the level of detail and quality of animation
isn't quite what we're used to today.
It's just off-putting seeing this clown's
deformed face, and the way those balls float
in the air is unnatural.
There's something off about the music, that
is, before the music just stops and he looks
directly into the camera.
That's just so creepy!
The ending of this is really depressing for
a PIXAR film too, the dream ends and the unicycle
just cries in the corner for almost 30 seconds.
Then it just ends.
This clown also makes a little cameo in Toy
Story 2.
Another PIXAR clown appeared more recently
in 2015 with Inside Out when two of Riley's
emotions, Joy and Sadness try to sneak in
the part of her brain that contains her biggest
fears.
*snoring*
The only thing scarier than a creepy clown,
is a giant creepy clown.
Jangles seems to have been a birthday party
clown that psychologically scorned Riley.
What makes him terrifying is similar to what
makes Pennywise so unnerving, which is the
fact that he's crazy and unpredictable.
And did I mention giant?
This movie is more recent, so I wasn't a kid
when it came out, but if I had been, I'm sure
my nightmares would be filled with that laugh.
"Birthday?!"
"Oh man.
Follow us!"
"Nothing like a good scare to wake you up,
right?"
Speaking of nightmare clowns, how did this
make it into a kids movie?
A lot of kids are already afraid of going
to the doctor, so the fact that Pee Wee's
Big Adventure then takes that fear and throws
clowns into the mix is just not going to go
over well for them.
Not to mention that they seem to be using
torture devices to fix this bike and the whole
dream devolves into some kind of nightmarish
hellscape.
"Ha, hahaha!"
And moving right along from one nightmare
would to another, who could forget the Clown
with the Tear Away Face from Nightmare Before
Christmas?
"I am the clown with the tear-away face!
Here in a flash and gone without a trace!"
The fact that the clown's true face is just
a black void is so disturbing compared to
the other characters who simply have a spooky
form, like a skeleton, or a Boogeyman.
It's not a scary movie despite being about
Halloween, but a clown with a black void under
his face has become known the scariest part
of the movie for a lot of people who watched
this as kids.
But the 90s clown horror does not end there.
Air Bud of things, has a crazy clown in it.
Like Jangles, it's the psychopathic tendencies
from a birthday clown that get you here.
As soon as you see this rusty clown truck
come barreling over the hill to start the
movie, you know it means trouble...
Outside of the crudely applied makeup, one
thing that puts you on edge about this guy
is the evidence of anger issues.
He is a bit less scary then some of the others
I've mentioned because of his clumsiness,
but there's still something off-putting about
a birthday clown who hates kids.
"I HATE BIRTHDAY PARTIES!
I HATE KIDS!
I HATE BEING A CLOWN!"
There are also hints of alcoholism, which
can turn anyone into a monster, and the fact
that it's happening to a clown makes it that
much worse.
The next one is from a TV show, not a film,
but since Are You Afraid of the Dark is an
anthology series, it could really be considered
more of a collection of short films so I'm
gonna count it.
"Yeah!
What kind of strange stuff happens on the
ride?"
"Well that's what the kids wanted to know.
Especially Wee-Gee!"
And also, it is intended to be scary for kids...
But you know what?
It's my channel, I can do what I want and
I'm talking about it!
Zeebo the Clown is from an episode called
"The Tale of Laughing in the Dark".
Zeebo is actually the ghost of a runaway circus
clown who's cigarette butt started the fire
that ended his life while hiding out in an
amusement park spookhouse.
This one definitely has the coolest backstory.
And I always love some good creepy clown music.
"It's the most fun in the park!
When you're laughing..."
Zeebo plays more on suspense than it does
shock value.
We don't actually see the real ghost of Zeebo,
only this disturbing prop.
But when Josh steals the clown's nose to prove
his bravery, Zeebo definitely begins to haunt
him at home.
It's never fully revealed if Zeebo's ghost
can be seen, or if this creepy carny who can
be seen smoking at the end is actually the
ghost of Zeebo out of makeup.
One thing's for sure, I wouldn't want to be
the one to hear this clown's laughter in the
dark.
And finally, we have the creepiest clown to
have graced the screen of a kids movie.
Have you noticed that 4/7 clowns so far have
appeared in nightmares?
That's probably not a coincidence.
This last one is no exception.
It comes from the 1987 Disney movie, The Brave
Little Toaster.
A movie about five household appliances looking
for their old master.
A movie that has no business being this creepy.
Just roll it.
"Run."
If they were trying to ruin every kid's childhood,
they got the design of this guy right, he
just looks sinister.
You may have seen YouTuber Colossal is Crazy
repurpose this image to be his logo.
The clown himself may actually be a reference
to the firefighter clowns from Dumbo, although
this is much scarier.
Every thing from the lighting to the voice
to the towering perspective makes this clown
the stuff of every kid's nightmare, and to
top it all off, Disney always has to have
a dark side, and the suicide references suggested
by imagery of a fork in the toaster or a toaster
in the bathtub make this scene absolutely
chilling... and that's before you even get
to the sound of the clown's creepy sadistic
laugh.
If any of these clowns left a mark on your
childhood, be sure to give this video a like,
and go down to the comments to let me know
about any other creepy things you've seen
in kids movies.
If you're interested in topics like this,
check out some of my other Creepy Things videos
and remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications and I'll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.